Swampy forest clearings like this one are found
throughout the Congo Basin
in the local language.
They are known as Bais
free from the shade of the canopy.
Smaller plants flourish, creating
vital pit stops for grazing animals
but Bais are more
than just forest clearings.
They are places where salt
and other minerals
are hidden in the ground.
Many elephants are nervous
being out in the open
due to poaching
only under the cover of darkness.
Does this bull step out of the shadows
and into the Bai
filmed here
for the first time using only Moonlight,
he knows exactly
where to go.
The salt and minerals he needs
are buried in the riverbed,
and he has the perfect multi-tool to mine
for them
blowing jets of air,
he breaks up the sediments,
creating a rich, salty
soup.
His trunk acts as a jackhammer, cup
and straw.
He barely spills a drop.
The sound of the bull mining is a beacon
signaling to the more cautious
forest residents that tonight
this Bai is safe.